season one of House of the Dragon is
over and now it's time to rank the
episodes as usual this is my opinion and
without further Ado let's get into it
number 10 episode 6 The Princess and the
queen so even though this episode is at
the bottom of the list that doesn't mean
it's flat out bad it's just this episode
had the unfortunate circumstance of
being right after a 10-year time Jump so
every development is either a
reintroduction or throwing us into
something entirely new that doesn't
really make sense in the given context
the biggest Rift to me is Damon's
endpoint in episode 5 and starting point
for this episode we end with a man
killing his wife still being a nuisance
in King's Landing and saying that he's
going to claim his inheritance and
getting runestone for the latter we
never hear of this development again and
we never know if Damon actually
inherited runestone we actively set up a
conflict between Gerald Royce
challenging Damon in court but nothing
comes of this then Lena is now suddenly
betrothed to Daemon and they have two
kids this this is jarring to say the
least given that he just killed his last
wife and is still kind of obsessed with
renera so any scenes here are
immediately off-putting from how much of
a disconnection we have from where we
left off and this point in the story the
same thing applies to Rainier's
relationship with sir Harwin and other
minor plot lines like Alison spawn of
Laris and Sir Kristen the writers are
essentially skipping over the midpoint
of development for these plotlines to
the point that it dampens the impact of
their payoff the deaths of Sir Harwin
and Lena would have been significantly
stronger if we came to know who they
were like Lena's death in particular was
well executed but how can we feel that
bad for her when she was only in like
three scenes on a plot basis that's very
flawed but there are still some good
scenes here that make this episode
better than most of the later seasons of
Game of Thrones scenes like Rainier's
long Wonder of childbirth which
brilliantly shows off Emma drc's ability
to act getting to see the dragon Pit and
the introduction of all the new kitties
were well executed in the brief drama we
get get tired of Rainier's kids being
bastards and that complex Dynamic
infecting the right keep was great but
we needed more time of that so we could
breathe so this episode if anything
would have been significantly better if
there was one before this that handled
more setup number nine episode 5 we
light the way this episode is tough
because it's pretty solid up until the
ending the ending just leaves such a
sour taste in my mouth from how sloppily
executed it was and the amount of
questions that are left standing I don't
think I necessarily need to go into
detail since I've talked about this
scene extensively on two occasions
however I do think I overreacted a bit
in terms of Kristen's Arc as a character
that aspect I've come to like more in
him trying to redeem his honor by
proposing turanira in his overall quick
mental decline I just wish we
experienced Kristen's breakdown through
his own perspective and was more of a
rich character moment instead of it
being a convoluted mess of confusion
shown primarily from the perspective of
the dinner table then this is also
exaspered by there being a time Jump
after this so any confusion you have
isn't answered and we have to make
assumptions that definitely sucks and
this flaw essentially stems into the
next episode in which there are a lot of
plot lines that needed more scenes now
since there is a big flaw does this
episode particularly outweigh it with
any great scenes to me that question is
kind of a no every scene on average is
pretty good within the show but not much
else within this episode really stands
out to me Kristen's Arc is the main
emphasis here but there are two small
scenes that I think are deemed a bit
that makes it better than episode 6
which are Arlo's Fair world at Allison
and viserys talking to Lionel strong
Otto's farewell is so juicily dramatic
as he shatters Allison's naivity and he
makes her see the truth and the danger
that is rhaenyra it's the first time we
don't see Otto hold back as he brutally
manipulates and scares the [ __ ] out of
his own daughter and the acting from
both of them is Stellar along with it
being in the rain that matches the
intensity of their dialogue and as you
usual resaphon's delivery is golden a
different mirror succeeds in war will
follow do you understand then for
viserys's monologue him recollecting his
life and asking Lino if he was the good
King was very sweet kind of brings up an
interesting internal struggle if it
would have been better to be remembered
more for going to war or having a
peaceful role that people may not
remember as much essentially solidifying
visceros as someone who cares more about
the realm than his own ego an overall
good episode that would have been higher
on my list if it wasn't for the misfire
of the ending number eight episode nine
the green Council I was honestly pretty
torn between placing this episode as
number nine or eight however I think
this episode just barely beats out we
light the way since the ending isn't as
bad in the opening of the episode is
outstanding that small council meeting
has such a thick layer of dread over it
as we eagerly anticipate what these
leeches are going to do then for
everything to unfold and slowly start to
deteriorate array and explode was so
good developments like Auto planning all
this before this meaning Allison
freaking out about that and their
intentions Lord beesberry's Death and
westerling finally challenging Kristen
made this scene consistently riveting
it's just too bad that the scene wasn't
longer because I could have watched what
happened there for a very long time
because after this point I think the
episode loses some of its steam during
the long search for aegon and that just
comes down to the plot because this plot
point isn't as interesting in comparison
to most story developments since it's
essentially our characters wandering
around flea bottom that and we're
primarily following Eric and Eric and it
was very hard to track who was who
during their growing divide as brothers
like I still don't know which Eric is
the good one since they have the same
damn name I think this whole portion of
the episode would have been better if we
spent more time in the right keep
because I was infinitely more intrigued
by Otto being a menacing ruler enforcing
Lords to change allegiances I think most
people would agree that they'd rather or
see that then listen to misaria drawn on
about flea bottom or whatever and her
annoying accent that you need to turn on
subtitles for when your blood
but I guess it's nice we're getting some
World building then going into the
ending I think aegon had a simple and
effective Arc that allowed us to quickly
sympathize with him a man going from
despising his existence not being loved
and feeling like he has no place in this
world to finally being accepted being
loved and getting a sense of meaning
from becoming the king surprisingly a
good Arc then the unfortunate rhaenys
conundrum happens again I don't think
this is as bad as the ending the episode
5 which I assume some people will
disagree on but at least it isn't flat
out confusing because her reasoning for
not killing The Greens at least makes
sense it just feels like a half flat out
moment to try and give rhaenys a badass
event that doesn't even come across that
way since she kills hundreds of
Innocents so it definitely needed some
rewriting in comparison to Kristen
seeing that on top of needing rewrites
needed additional scenes to clear up
what the hell was happening number 7
episode 4 King of the narrow sea we are
essentially out of the territory of
episodes that have bad aspects that
weigh them down for this episode The
reason why I'd put it a bit lower in
comparison to the others is mostly the
plot where nearer's lust-driven
adventure with Damon and him dumping her
wasn't my favorite episodic debacle
firstly I felt a bit confusing as a
Damon's motivations because his
intention was to soil Rainier for
marriage so he could marry her himself
thus becoming King but that plane is
pretty ridiculous given that visceros
would never buy that so then was he
actually lying in that moment to viserys
did Damon improvise that plan to hide
the fact that he almost fell in love
with reniera but stopped himself
although in episode 7 he says that he
spared renira in that moment so that
would back up his plan of ruining Her
Image to marry her himself so yeah that
felt a little convoluted to say the
least but I still really enjoy the
dynamic between Ranier and Damon and
their overall Night Out in King's
Landing was cool that and the writer's
paralleled this fun adventure with
Allison's relationship with Sarah Paris
which was devoid of life and enjoyment
this then leads to a romantic scene with
sir Kristen Cole which at first I loved
but now that I hate sir Kristen it makes
me upset seeing this that doesn't hurt
the quality of the episode it just makes
me salty ironically out of all the spicy
conflict the thing that intrigued me the
most was Otto having to tell visceros
the hard truth about ranura that made
for a crazily awkward scene and seeing
Otto struggle to deliver the news was so
pleasing because we'd never seen him
this worried before then rhaenyra
convincing viserys to remove Otto's hand
made for a great ending to the episode
those are my favorite aspects and the
rest was alright so in comparison to the
other episodes that have great plot
points I'm going to like those a bit
more number six episode one The Heirs of
the Dragon normally the first episode
for different shows tends to skew
towards one of the Lesser episodes since
they are tasked with having to do a lot
of setup and Exposition but The Heirs of
the Dragon doesn't do this only in the
opening scene do we get Exposition and
to be fair it's kind of necessary to
establish where we are in the history of
Westeros after this though the writers
essentially plant us right into an
already existing world and do very
little Exposition they seamlessly blend
us into this narrative and allow the
audience to learn who the characters are
by seeing them react to different forms
of conflict no expository dialogue is
needed when each character is being
molded by different obstacles that tests
them like right away viserys is tested
by the birth complications of his new
child and then having to deal with
succession issues after the death of his
wife Damon trying to find some form of
purpose and dealing with the reality of
not being air anymore Bernier navigating
through all those obstacles while taking
on the responsibility of becoming the
new Heir and different Side characters
briefly cutting in in each scene to try
and sway each character's Minds with
their own wants and Wishes the show
quickly establishes and fully develops
each of its main characters as we are
thrown into an engaging story with
outstanding conflict like the birth
scene was so horrific and tragic that it
really sets the tone for the story to
come not to mention that a lot of the
dialogue scenes were all very
interesting especially when the topic of
succession comes up and we see viserys
break down and everyone trying to
influence him with their own benefits
then there's also a fun tournament with
jousting to add some spectacle into the
episode so overall this opening episode
is well balanced and acts as a perfect
introduction to House of the Dragon
Number 5 episode 2 the Rogue Prince this
may be an unpopular opinion but I like
the Rook Prince a little more than the
first episode this episode opens
immediately with a haunting feeling as
we first see what the crab feeder is
doing this both gives us some great
imagery on top of it giving what
cordless has to say some weights because
before this we didn't really know what
was happening in the stepstones so
quickly and efficiently this opening
makes us excited for this upcoming
conflict this then leads into a small
council meeting and in this scene we see
where nearer finally speak out which
essentially teases her independent
attitude and that leader quality is
starting to break through not only does
she have these triumphant character
moments but we also break renira down in
two separate scenes where she deals with
the loss of her mother and viserys
having to move on and find a new wife
each of these scenes hits a beautiful
emotional depth that absorbs the
audience with Millie's entrancing
performance this is to me what sold the
actors so well these small character
moments where they simply talk to one
another and go through a vast array of
emotions drips with so much Intrigue
these scenes are also imbued with a
great point of conflict in which if a
Series has to deal with having to find a
new wife this Dynamic has a lot of depth
because every character has a stake in
it and can add something new like
everyone having their own mischievous
motivations and seeing viscers go along
with some of them like talking with
Elena was funny then this isn't even
mentioning the best part which is the
10th showed on a Dragonstone between the
Otto and Daemon the amount of tension
within this scene was so powerful from
the music slowly building up the fog
obstructing the Sun and creating a tense
atmosphere how unpredictable Damon is
and karaxi is showing up made this seem
so fun to watch then it takes an
unpredictable turn where Nero shows up
to solve the confrontation without any
Bloodshed thus acting as her big moments
and this moment also unlocks her theme
that she essentially earns Here
andronera's theme is probably my
favorite throughout the entire show the
Rogue Prince is pretty great through and
through and even the cinematography is
at its best in my opinion
number four episode three second of his
name initially I wasn't a huge fan of
the first half of the episode but I've
come to really like the journeys that
both were near and viserys go on the
parallels to how they both treat their
anguishes were interesting since we're
nearer chooses to run away and be
rebellious while viserys chooses to
drown himself in wine seeing him grapple
with the annoyance of politicking and
wondering if he made the right decision
to make her near his Heir allows us to
see if it serves without any barriers
kings are always really reserved but
here he's pouring out so many emotions
that we are allowed to witness and feast
on like the bonfire in particular was
the peak of the episode in my opinion
because of this then rhaenyra also boils
over to a degree and lets out all of her
anger while killing the boar she's so
overcome with the responsibilities of
growing up having to marry and being a
pawn for her father in terms of politics
that it's driving her crazy so her
showing back up to the camp drenched in
blood makes her seem like a badass and
Commander respect I also like the small
details for how and being kind of turned
on by that kind of foreshadowing the
future this dual Journey has some great
character development and even the
resolution afterward and King's Landing
was pretty touching the series deciding
to let Rainier choose who to marry was a
great compromise but yet again that's
not necessarily a good choice to make as
a king then we have the stepstones
conflict to me the best aspect of this
battle is easily Damon Targaryen this
was a great showcase for the man where
he risks everything to prove himself and
even turns down help from his brother
the rush he makes was some intense
action and I hope people have moved away
from the Aero controversy because relax
the man still gets hit like three times
my only issue with this portion of the
episode is the fact that it doesn't
really last that long the actual battle
only lasts like 2 minutes and then it
quickly ends when Damon walks out with a
crab feeder's corpse it gives off a bit
of an anticlimactic feeling and if they
had more impressive slash longer takes
of action following Our Heroes then this
episode would maybe crack my top three
for the season but it's still pretty
good and acts as a fun final sequence to
an already great episode
number three episode 10 The Black Queen
some people may feel compelled to put
this episode at number one because of
the insane final scene with vegar but I
think this finale has a bit too much
setup and that's in regards to wartime
preparations it's nice to see but it's
not something that you would expect
within a finale that's normally packed
with a lot of payoff which the payoff we
do get is amazing we're Nera having a
miscarriage was extremely uncomfortable
and drastically increased attention at
the beginning of the episode reniro
becoming Queen was immensely uplifted by
Ramin jawadi's wonderful score Corliss
finally allying himself with renera was
so satisfying when his theme played and
the death of luceris was batshit
insanity and had some of the best action
intention build up we've ever seen if
the episode was just these scenes with
maybe one setup scene cut out or even
just the ending 10-minute sequence on
repeats then it would have been hard to
not put this episode at number one but
since there's a lot of Roundtable
discussions within this episode it's it
slows down that fast and Fun Pace
cutting out one of the setup scenes
could be better to keep the pace moving
more quickly but it's hard to say that
since they are needed and are still good
this is obviously a minor issue and
these are things I need to address when
the top three episodes are so close in
quality I can honestly argue why this
episode in the next two could be number
one and at the end of the day it will
come down to opinion one thing that we
can all agree on though is how perfect
the ending of the season is aim and
chasing luceris on vegar was so intense
given the size difference and the
setting of the scene hiding away this
massive threat in the Thundering clouds
was terrifying and the action was
perfectly presented by not hiding the
VFX in terrible lighting conditions the
fact that we can follow the action with
ease is refreshing and it never breaks
our immersion 10 minutes of pure
adrenaline and this scene alone carries
the episode
number two episode seven driftmark when
this episode released it was my favorite
and it almost retained that spot the
reason it was there in the first place
is that this episode has a perfect
collection of scenes nothing feels out
of place there's no downbeat and it just
keeps getting better the episode opened
strong with an ensemble of characters
interacting with each other I tend to
love these scenes because of how much
depth is here and the number of small
interactions that happens between every
character everyone has a moment to shine
here and the writers officially set up
certain dynamics that will be an
integral later on then we have an
engrossing debate between rhaenys and
Corliss their motivation is perfectly
contrast with each other which allows
for some great dialogue two lines in the
scene are even quoted in the trailer and
then we have renir and Damon on the
beach now I like the writing of this
scene it's just that due to the dark
lighting we can't really see their
reactions that well kind of feels like a
hindrance in an otherwise integral scene
between these two characters who are
getting emotional but that's the only
small flaw within this episode this
leads into Eamon taming vegar and this
was a great display of awe-inspiring
scale the action as Eamon tries to
desperately hold on was so gripping this
is followed by aemond having a violent
confrontation with her near his children
which I honestly did not know how that
scene was going to play out so an aemond
loses an eye I was genuinely surprised
this sets up the best scene of the
episode in which Allison demands Justice
for that so many aspects about the scene
are amazing we have viserys desperately
trying to keep everyone at Bay the
awkward silence as everyone acknowledges
the truth about our nearest children the
harsh back and forth dialogue and the
explosive ending as Allison vs raniero
with viserys's dagger truly a great
Climax and somehow the episode doesn't
end here it ends with a crazy Encore of
laner's fake out death which even that
scene has some impressive writing in
that the writers lead you to believe
that laner actually dies but doesn't and
gets a happy ending this episode is flat
out stacked and has great character work
action plot twists love and even Auto
Hightower gets reinstated as a hand
easily top two worthy and is really
close to being in my top spot but the
next episode has something very special
about it number one episode 8 the lord
of the tides yeah you know why this
episode is at number one the Last Supper
is easily the best scene in the season
and is a pure Rush of happiness every
time I watch it I don't know how many
people here watch Rick and Morty but I'm
like the Rick who's held prisoners they
make him watch the same Happy scene over
and over to farm serotonin but for me
that scene on replay is visera smiling
it's such a purely wholesome moment that
I couldn't help but shed a tear when
first watching it throughout the entire
season we come to love visceros and the
tragedy of his entire bodily Decay mixes
feel so bad for him so seeing this last
moment in which he gets to witness his
family be happy one more time his
extreme really precious and is not
something I was expecting to come out of
this dark show that and the rest of this
scene is so great in which he Reveals
His Face to everyone and gives a
heartwarming speech along with renera
trying to reconcile with Allison so this
is the perfect example of the Calm
before the storm then for the rest of
the episode there's really no down
moments Ranier and Damon visit viserys
while the man is in agony Allison having
to deal with a handmaid getting raped by
aegon which in particular was a great
showcase for the handmade actor in terms
of acting Alison roasting aegon him
being a douche renera awkwardly meeting
up with the rhaenys after killing her
son viserys's makeup routine and some
other quick scenes that are equally
intriguing however this wouldn't be my
number one spot without another standout
scene which is the throne room debate
for the succession of driftmark
throughout this entire scene you know
this hearing is rigged in vaman's favor
so you have no idea how her Nero will
come out of the situation on top and I
assumed she wouldn't so to have busy tea
show up like an absolute Legend works as
an excellent twist and is also severely
uplifted by Ramin jawadi going ham on
the score and I also love the fact that
the director draws this moment out so
much by having the Stars slowly walk
across the entire Throne Room really
emphasizing how much of an impressive
feat this is then vaman explodes and
Damon removes his head so overall great
escalation in terms of plot points and
twists within the scene and it just
keeps getting better as you go through
it with this shocking death Triumph a
moment from viserys one of the most
heartwarming moments in Game of Thrones
history and a collection of solid scenes
in between those bangers mix this a
goaded episode of House of the Dragon
thank you for watching and let me know
in the comments what your ranking would
be
[Music]
foreign